truck drivers for 33 years I don't like
just getting up and driving to the
factory downtown working eight or ten I
heard driving back home every day that's
not for me
when I found out that they needed truck
drivers in Iraq it's just like the light
bulb went off I told my wife this is
what I want to do it might not have been
the best thing for my family but it's
something that I needed to do for me at
that time in my life I needed to get
something back to my country 43 years
old and this was an opportunity and I
was not going to miss we were based out
of the camp anaconda just north of
Baghdad
we were truck drivers in the States but
none of us is driven the truck in a war
zone
April 9th was the one-year anniversary
the fall of Baghdad turn our safety
briefing with our military escorts and
said we've got some executors when put
in your trucks that had never had
with 19 trucks being truck I mean I was
after Vincent we had a lot of trucks
that you get for the IEDs and is I'm
going into this area I knew that this is
where these things could happen anything
is gonna happen it's gonna happen on the
stretch of highway right here
almost
slam
there's one Iraqi insurgents as a key
point of that
you know started across the road and I
look down this alley and it's just a
dream of insurances and I'm thinking
this is a done deal
these guys just walked up to me Gordon
pulls on that
this was my first day
Kathy woke up and I'm here in
helicopters off in the distance I looked
up and I saw a piece of this piece of
wood hanging down from the rafter and I
reached up and got ahold of it with my
left arm and I pull down as hard as I
could I grab that timber and I shove it
through that hole trying to get acted on
these helicopters I'm hearing they're
moving I've got to get out of it
and I gave it a big shove push them
inside and the door pushed open and I
ran out
- big Chinooks work we're headed in my
direction I'm going home today